it turns out the value of X would be 84 when Y is &amp; and Z is 1. Nice work if you
figured that one out. We know the values for X1, Y1, and Z1 so we plug those in
here. We are looking for the X value when Y is 7 and Z is 1, so we plug in 7 and
1 in these positions. We can think of these numbers as being the second case
We're looking for x 2, which is x, and we know the second y value is 7, and the
second z value is 1. We use these lists to make our substitution. We simplify
this right hand side to get 5 42nds. Next we multiply both sides of the equation
by the LCD, 42x. Essentially, this is the same as cross-multiplying. So we get
5x on the right and 420 on the left. We divide both sides by 5 to get x is equal
to 84.